hey how's it going bros my name is Peter
pop today
oh my god every once in a while a game
appears that is so good and
life-changing that I just feel like I
need this for you bros right now you
bros need to see this game you've seen
the title you know what this shit's is
about shower with your dad simulator
oh it's 2015 edition here that's gonna
be a good one do your steel shower with
your dad that's what we're gonna find
out today unless you didn't know for
some reason so we can select the shower
from data thought that a flood or enduro
dad where it's gonna start off with
enduro dad did you get a haircut yet son
I got them all of them what the [ __ ] is
this
alright let's just go let's just go
alright here we are this is ok I need to
shower my dad I got an achievement oh
wait I need to shower with my dad
there's so many dads best game best game
hey or that's my dad
this is my dad I'm gonna share with you
three dad streak family reunion oh my
god I got a five dad streak coming back
Nev okay that was a close one
oh my god this is so intense I never
been this excited to shower with my
daddy
notice me daddy saying oh my god I'm so
good at sharing with my dad I'd shower
every day son every day I shower with my
dad son oh god I'm slow now damn it
gotta watch out for the elk guard again
I've been crippled yeah magnum there you
what huh huh so many points yeah gotta
share with my dad there where we
showering daddy can daddy daddy
oh oh this is so intense it's running
out of time got a no daddy let me shower
with you place I've never showered with
my dad I don't understand this game
maybe like my siblings but that's
different right and I'm young right you
don't shower with your dad right no good
does this ever end or do I just go
forever
I'm Little League I can literally go
forever best game let's go to 100 and
see what happens I regret oh my god no
no no god dammit not that's not my dad
that's really awkward best game we
unlock extra soy soy that's English
moisturizing a loved one is moist let's
do the data flan sound what happens win
the lumberjack doesn't know which tree
to cut next he gets stumped okay alright
this one time we're gonna try Johnny and
Robin so we just look for the ginger dad
daddy daddy what Oh should they change
the daddies change Oh
I mean the sons change alright so camp
double points cuz I got the soap daddy's
got the soap come on wash me baby yeah
daddy's got the soap I love when daddy
has a sir this is the greatest game of
all time I've been doing pretty good I
gotta say I'm pretty proud of myself oh
look at that [ __ ] boy yes shower all day
shower all night
shower with my daddy and it fails
alright [ __ ] who would have thought you
showering with your dad could be but how
will I know well oh god Howard I think
this one oh thank god ah this one uh
this one this one this is so hard
this is not good when you shower that oh
god oh god I don't think I saw it I got
it huh-huh oh god yes
ah this is so intense this one what I
ran out of time
no that's my dad that was my dad are you
kidding me
you don't think I know my dad what the
[ __ ] this game it's glitched I've been
tricked
okay whatever what else do we have all
right dad divisions good job using likes
talkin music I used to have shampoo
addiction
don't worry Santa I'm clean now that was
a that was a funny joke
alright so we need to grab our dad and
that that's all I know
that's literally all I know okay I use
some mouse got it okay here we go can't
wait to share with my dad that's my dad
that's my dad do I eat [ __ ] no I'm wrong
dad I fished said the wrong fish me
daddy
this is literally the most offensive
game of all time it's me daddy I mean
let me fish you daddy let me fix you
daddy I feel like this one is randy's
from South Park's father just me okay
don't you hate when you just grab the
wrong dad to shower with whoever made
this game is clearly a genius this is
clearly the game greatest game of all
time people will look back on this game
centuries from now and say back then
they knew what they were talking about
when they were talking about art we're
running out of dads a running out of
dads no dammit we were so close
god damn it we were so close what that
[ __ ] good menu bro Jesus Christ how
do we unlock it all right let's look up
the codes well apparently this game is
so fresh that no one knows any codes for
it so that's that's cool this one
requires dad loadable content dammit I
wish I had that dad where are the
remotes batteries they ran out I gave
them away what I
away free of charge haha son wedding the
skeleton cross the road why dad because
he had no guts and ha ha ha
suddenly son jokes I'm hungry dad hi
hungry I'm dad
yes Bravo thank you all right well this
is clearly the greatest game of all time
I'm gonna quit my youtube channel right
here but thank you so much for watching
I'll leave a link to this piece of [ __ ]
and the description in case you want to
shower with your dad which you obviously
want to do but again limit like and I'll
see you with your dad no wait